and this is great I have my phone with
me and my beautiful wife with me
you know what can be better a little bit
when I went into prison I was already
very grateful I was on a great road you
know mentally and spiritually but I had
the time to work on everything else
first
everybody just exhale yeah we just like
breathe for just a minute yes yes
because this is the first time you've
kind of done something like this right
all right like a big event yeah oh my
god
to be a free man it's uh to God switch
its off it's fantastic you know I have
my beautiful wife next to me I'm healthy
I'm sober back at work with my best
friends on the number one show on MTV
and just living the dream
what has the last week been like since
you got out of prison well the last
eight months I've been dreaming of what
my first days would be like first and
foremost I wanted to spend some time
with my beautiful wife I wanted to have
a naked pizza party did that happen yes
that happens and then I slowly wanted to
just get back to work but first start
with the basics okay the basics which is
Fitness family fun and don't forget the
finances because you don't want to end
up back in prison what did you miss the
most I'd have to say that the thing that
I miss the most is probably my beautiful
wife makes me take your freedom I would
say for granted sometimes and once it is
sort of taken away from you you're
taking advantage of once you get out not
necessarily every minute but every
second every meal every conversation I
cherish with my beautiful wife with my
friends I love my job so I feel like I
want such an awesome road and we're very
excited to see what the future has to
offer you mentioned you're grateful for
every meal I know yeah yeah what's your
last meal before you went to prison
last meal out the last meal was probably
I probably was ordering some sort of
fast-food delivery because I was you
know ordering everything you know when
you realize that your freedom is being
taken away from
you you're like you know what I'm not
gonna get good food in prison so I'm
gonna put a McDonald's I'm gonna order
Wendy's I'm going chick-fil-a we're
turning up and living our best life and
I did that and I you know I gained a
couple pounds and but I had the time
once I was in prison to concentrate on
being my best self and you know losing
weight your first meal out of prison
what's it the naked pizza party or what
day it was all the toppings we did about
six different yes we did we did a sauce
pie which is my favorite mm-hmm regular
margarita sausage peppers and onions he
wanted plane plane and then properly
robbing sausage
side of fried shrimp side of chicken
fingers side of french fries yeah don't
forget to stop to dive so ders yeah so
what is the real-life such of being in
prison today the routine the real
situation in prison is not like the
movies I'll have to tell you that okay
what I did I went to sleep every night
at 10:00 p.m. I woke up every morning at
7 a.m. you did fasted cardio for about
an hour
I was practicing intermittent fasting
while I was in prison my window of
intermittent fasting was between 16
hours and 17 hours on the weekdays and
18 and 19 on the weekends I had to
continually challenge myself whether it
was in the gym or end or diet as well as
reading books and trying to progress you
know spiritually as well because if you
do not keep yourself busy in there I
don't handle for the devil I saw a lot
of things in prison where some guys
weren't doing those things and you saw
depression and anxiety sort of you know
and taking control so how did you keep
yourself busy I worked out between two
to three times per day on holidays
especially three times because you know
on your birthday or Easter or something
maybe if you're in your feels a little
bit you're like you know what today I'm
gonna do something to make my future
self proud and I put
like two to three days as well as
intermittent fasting I would read books
I read the Bible I love to read
magazines I would email and speak to my
wife once a day I would email and speak
to my best friends
you know once a day and that really
helped so when you get in your fields
yes
how sad did you get at times it's
natural you know just like anything in
life I used to tell myself that you've
been assigned this mountain to show
others it can be moved you know and for
me this was prison but for other people
it could be anxiety it could be
depression
it could be divorce it could be
unemployment you have a job or a
responsibility to become better or
bitter and I chose to be better when you
got depressed how did it feel and how
did you tackle it um I tackled it just
like I just said I would wake up every
morning and I would do a very similar
schedule so you would just stay on a
routine I was gonna grab yourself up
I was very regimented I stayed in my
intrument fasting which is not easy if
anybody knows about fasting for 16 to 19
hours a day it is not easy you feel
almost like a reward once you've
finished a day like wow I did 19 hours
today along with working out 2 to 3
times along with reading a book or or
the Bible or magazine so I was I felt
very accomplished staying busy in prison
did you read the Bible before you went
to prison no I didn't I was very
spiritual you know and I also went to
recovery all the way up into prison I
had about three years at that time I'm
about to be coming up on four years
which I imagine very grateful for and I
wear my sobriety on my shoulder like a
badge of honor you talked about seeing
others kind of get down yes yes yeah
what is the craziest thing you witnessed
in prison
um you know what I just saw a lot of
guys and with where the depression
anxiety was getting the best of them I
saw them like literally just like
staring at the wall not doing anything
like you know that you just you know you
can see how it was eating at them you
know the isolation being away from their
family the most and I met a lot of a lot
of
people in prison a lot of you know
regular you know people with hopes and
dreams and families and doctors and
lawyers and accountants you know I and I
heard their story firsthand but it also
helped me come from my perspective to to
to know that to learn from your mistakes
and turn your ELLs into lessons and I
had a very positive outlook from day one
to the end of my eight months did you
make good friends in prison people that
you will keep in touch with I don't know
about keep in touch with I did make good
friends in there it's not it's not your
job when you go to prison to make
friends it really isn't
it's your job to survive you know and
get out you seem so upbeat about it I'm
entering Lauren I'm kind of picturing
him in there helping those who did get
depressed he was that's exactly what he
was doing I had some people that were in
there reached out to me when they got
out and said you know I just want to
thank you for being such a big part of
his life and he made my time go by
faster there learn and challenge and
grow myself to become better while in
there and he made he really helped a lot
of people out in there and also from
being there he helped me like I would
get upset when he was home like I think
sometimes I was more of a more upset
than he was that he was there and he
would email me and motivate me he liked
me and encouraged me every day while he
was in prison which not many people can
do eight months you were able to do this
do you ever feel like you were hanging
by a thread no no I didn't feel like I
was hanging for a thread I just felt
that everything in my life had prepared
me for this journey and although very
uncomfortable I lived one day at a time
every single day you know tried to be my
best self or better than the day before
and then move forward and that was it
and I'll be honest with you I was very
successful I had lost you know over
thirty five pounds in there so the food
was not great then no no the food was
not good but the guys in there like me
you know if I needed extra salad or
extra vegetables those were some of the
the ingredients in there that were so
prized fresh you know salad or fresh
vegetables and I needed that on a daily
basis to be on a diet and get the old
situation back so
you know I did that for eight months and
but it could have been the opposite I
could have went to prison and these guys
maybe they didn't like Jersey Shore
maybe they didn't like the situation
maybe even like Big Daddy sitch you know
but they did so you walked in and they
all knew who you were yeah and and what
kind of welcome was that for you um it
was nice I kind of the first day I went
in there I kind of wanted to be left
alone it's it's a bit of a sensory
overload and part of your brain is
thinking like is is it like the movies
and it wasn't like the movies the first
I think the second day and then I got a
haircut there was a barber shop in the
salon and by no means was it a
comfortable situation being one day away
from your loved ones it's unacceptable
but it's manageable and you can survive
it how would you rate the food one to
ten it is probably like the worst school
lunch you've ever had and if you're
trying to lose weight and get healthy it
could be almost impossible you know and
you talk about it not being a
comfortable situation wasn't I have been
in prison for eight months and you are
not sleeping in a comfortable bed and
it's not even a mattress it's like a pad
for eight months
you're not eating good food for eight
months you're away from your loved ones
for eight months so you're sharing a
bathroom with over a hundred savages for
eight months you're being told what to
do and what you know what you can and
can't for eight months if you add it all
that in you can see how you can see guys
walk you know letting depression and
anxiety get the best of them plus also
I'm not able to work as well I'm not
able to support my family I was lucky
enough that I filmed so much of Jersey
Shore before I left that while I was in
prison I was watching Jersey Shore on
the TV and I was proud of myself you
have two in touch with your Jersey Shore
yes they have a system in prison almost
like an app it's called true links and
my friends and my wife and my mother and
family were able to email me on a daily
basis I was it was unbelievable the
amount of love and support of of the
fans writing in and the letters and
things like that but every single day I
would look forward to getting an email
from my wife or getting
email from Pauly D or Snooki it was it
really made the time fly by email do the
most from the cast or did you speak to
them on the phone as well no you only
got 300 minutes a month so I reserved
those special minutes for the permissive
situation here on the left right and I
used my email for obviously every day
with my wife and you know Jersey Shore
crew and my mother and family and stuff
so who did you communicate with the most
out of the cast you know what they all
communicated with me like almost every
single week you know they really did I
mean some of them even wrote like a
handwritten yes yes I was surprised a
lot of people can wrote in handwritten a
letter
it was some label Snooki Jett who Polly
I wrote the letters who wrote the
letters you know what if you were a my
let's say who brought the letter yeah
Ronnie wrote the letter yeah and I and
hey Ronnie wrote the letter and and
Snooki and Pauly in today well I had
emailed me the most so Ronnie's
handwritten letter yeah I was very
surprised when I got it
was it emotional what can you share
about that letter um it was just like my
friends all of them they said pretty
much the same thing that they couldn't
believe the strength that me and my wife
had and then you were able to go through
this process with such grace and class
and they were so proud of me and they
can't wait to you know see me get home
and you know get back to work and and
film on Jersey Shore who came to visit
all of them how many time um I would say
like a couple times you know they all
came my wife came once a week the Jersey
Shore crew came you know every two
months they would come let's talk about
your marriage and dealing with this you
got married last November
mm-hmm yes two months later yeah yeah
slammer yes how did that make you feel
it was a unique situation
sure but if anybody knows our backstory
it's kind of something that we were able
to just take on and I wasn't really
scared at in the beginning so we met 15
years ago we dated for like three to
four years in college college
sweethearts yeah it took a huge break
when Jersey Shore happen mm-hmm I was
working you know in the city and in my
career and he was doing his career on TV
mm-hmm TV show ended I moved back home
from New York to New Jersey
and we just bumped into each other and
we were immediately back together again
that was six years ago
so that was 2013 mm-hmm so we're best
friends you know we've experienced
everything together from good bad and
different and the most challenging thing
we went through together was his
recovery and we went through that a few
times and last year when he got
sentenced in October he had already been
almost three years clean and sober so
once we had put some significant time in
with his recovery
we were just became like a solid
foundation where nothing was really
scary to me we were able to survive it
and like thrive through it I mean it was
hard it was not easy at all I don't know
how people do it longer for years but it
definitely made us stronger for sure
this did not shake you after dealing
with addiction a higher recovery
yep recovery it was way harder way
harder than working yeah I would choose
prison or recovery talk to me about how
it was harder for you recovery was way
harder than prison and I believe that my
recovery over the past couple years had
prepared me for this journey to go
through you know prison I mean we didn't
think that I was gonna get jail time you
know we thought we were gonna get
probation but the judge had Eddie every
right to to give me the eight months and
we accepted that and we owned up to our
mistakes and we're accountable and our
main goal throughout the whole process
was to handle it with grace and class
just not only for ourselves but to show
the young generation out there how to to
handle adversity you know and move
forward and continue to be your best
even if you make mistakes
how did you maintain your marriage
during this eight-month prison sentence
I would go visit him every week so I
figured out conjugal visit no I wish not
allowed no in the beginning I went more
than once a week I went like twice a
week but then I had to figure out what
was working for me yeah I didn't want
her to drive three hours hi I'm in three
hours back I I just was nervous I didn't
want her to get you a car accident or
anything like that I just so then it
turned out to be once a week yeah once a
week visits in person and then daily
phone calls you know we do civic time
really emails we both wouldn't know each
other's schedule every day with the
email and working out a lot and just
doing things to keep my body productive
and you know being positive and healthy
what kind of transition has it been
since he's been home with you because
you got used to being on your own yes
very true yeah I had a little bit of
PTSD I think more than him
at first so the first day we came home
you know I'm used to being alone and I
have our dog at home but that's it so
when he was in the shower I actually
like won in there like opens the shower
door to see if he was still in there
because I'm just not used to it being
there but it's been amazing we're back
into our groove and working went right
into work so tell me the details of your
probation probation is very detailed but
it's pretty much the main goal is to
stay sober and to stay out of trouble
for two years along with community
service random drug tests yes handing
over financial records yes 500 hours of
community service okay so how hard will
it be to abide by all of these rules
well at the end of the day the way that
I live my life you know I don't lie
don't cheat I don't steal I don't drink
I don't drug I don't smoke I don't even
speed I'm on probation I can't afford
any misunderstandings so when you kind
of live that way
keeping your side of the street clean
we're human we make some mistakes but it
really you know makes life a lot easier
when you're living with integrity so I
don't think there will be an issue I
look forward to continuing to be my best
self and living my best life with my
beautiful life and he was already under
all
supervision throughout the whole case so
it's the same this one couldn't say yes
will you have an anemometer no that's
that's that's like so no ankle monitor
yeah bracelet no okay have you met your
probation officer yes I have I can't
necessarily speak about it but she was
really nice
okay really nice okay intimidating or oh
you like talk yeah oh she was tough but
at the end of day for doing all the
right things in your silver almost four
years there's no reason to you know you
know be on top of me like that what is
your biggest regret my biggest regret um
you know what I really I really don't
have any regrets because I wouldn't be
the man I am today if I didn't make
those mistakes I was careless when I was
in my 20s I was reckless you know I was
uneducated I let substance abuse get the
best of me and eventually five seven
years later I had to pay for some of
those you know mistakes but in my 30s
I'm older I'm wiser more mature
accountable responsible and ready to
handle whatever life you know throws at
you do you ever have regrets about doing
reality TV no I know I definitely don't
have any regrets about doing reality TV
I love my job I think I'm very good at
it and you are very good at it you're
very entertaining so you know hopefully
we have a long career of different types
of reality shows and we can continue to
entertain Millie do you think Fame
clouded your judgment no that's a very
tricky question because you know Fame
could cloud your judgment as well as
money and being in your 20s so but a I'd
have to say that before Fame and money I
was wild and I was reckless and I was
careless and I was immature and the
money and the fame just you know just
made it worse exacerbated yeah you know
how will you explain this season of life
to your kids this season of life this is
called making some mistakes when you're
in your 20s and Manning up in your 30s
and being accountable and handling
handling a negative situation with grace
in class what's the biggest change that
you have seen in
biggest change other than physically the
35 pound weight loss yes is a
significant one for sure
but honestly I didn't think he could get
more positive when he went in he was
already such a positive uplifting
looking at the bright side of every
situation in life and I think he even
elevated to another level of that with
his level of patience and learning that
and I could definitely use some more
patience in life so I inspired he
inspires me to be like that a little bit
more are you a changed man so you feel
like you're a changed man I definitely
feel like I'm a changed man you know it
really starts with my recovery though
I'll be honest with you I'm four years
clean it's over in a couple months and I
just practice you know living one day at
a time being my best self and you know
making sure that I'm you know the best
man I could be for my beautiful wife you
know the best son to my mother you know
best friend to my friends out there and
do the best job I can it work and and
then after that let go in that God
handle it have you seen the cast since
you were released yeah yeah we saw the
cast was at a day after yeah I think the
day after it was a day after we went
straight to work you know what was that
real I have one of the best jobs in the
country I think you know so being
yourself ya know just being myself and
and being authentic and being able to
articulate my emotions from the camera
so the viewer can relate what was that
reunion like with your friends oh it was
unbelievable it was it was just a lot of
emotions all at once and you know I was
very grateful to have such close
relationships with friends that I call
family today what would your message be
to your fans who have stood beside you
through this journey um I would have to
tell them that the comeback is truly
greater than the setback let's talk
about your brother yes he's still
incarcerated yes did you speak to him
have you visited him well I had to just
ask probation for permission to visit
him and that was like the other day so
other than that that's where we stand
right now because you need to ask
permission to to go to a prison how's he
doing he's doing good okay and remind me
you know years ago
he was your manager yes do you blame him
for what happened no no no the past is
in the past right now and my main focus
is you know making sure that he is
comfortable and that you know when he
gets out to you know greet him with open
arms and how long is his sentence two
years okay and he has served how much
eight months eight months so he's got
almost yours yeah yeah you might have a
year and a half but once you do more
than a year in a day you're entitled to
credit whether it's halfway house or
home confinement a lot of people don't
understand the whole process but since
he's been sentenced to two years he's
you know entitled to certain credits how
difficult has it been for your family to
have two sons to the only members yeah
in prison I mean listen it's a difficult
situation but at the end of the day you
have to rise to the occasion and
continue to move forward well will the
celebration look like when he too is
released from prison ah we'll definitely
have an awesome Sunday dinner ready for
it when my brother gets home you know
I'm sure my mom will make the meatballs
in the sauce and you know and you know
she probably makes them dessert actually
my mom this Sunday is making a whole
spread for me because I haven't gone
over yet we're gonna have chicken
cutlets fettuccine with peas and ham
baked clams chicken cutlets salad bread
and antipasto what was it like when you
saw your family first um I took my
mother and sister out and my brother my
other brother to a sushi dinner I wanted
some fresh food so I took them out for
dinner and then this week we're having a
Sunday Sunday dinner so the new the new
Mike yes 30/30 how many pounds oh I lost
36 pounds in prison 36 cents yeah okay
you aren't so much thinner than the last
time I saw you this so what is your
regimen going forward are you gonna yeah
you like this are you gonna try to lose
more weight you're gonna put more weight
on um no no I'm looking to probably stay
the way I am right now I'm about 185
that's the weight that I weighed in
college so that's like you know you're
fighting weight right there I'm very
proud that I was even able to get to
that going forward right now I'm going
to continue to intervene fast if I can
work out at least once a day maybe even
twice I will and I'm looking to unveil
the situation very shortly
and break the internet the internet and
so you the G and the GTL you kept up
with that yes now you're back how are
you gonna do or how happy are you to
embrace the whole GTL once again um
listen I'm so grateful just to be able
to be with my wife but at the same time
have the freedom to do what I want you
know I can go to the gym I can go get a
spray tan
I can get a manicure a pedicure a facial
you know without someone terry-yes
something with that big with that have
you gotten a tan since you've got no no
no I have not gotten to ten but I'm
willing to get a spray tan if you want
to recommend me someone yeah money it
looks good though yeah fair complexion
what are you thinking Lauren no I like
it I think he looks great you haven't
wasted any time no no no no I can
straight back to work I hit the ground
running we had that naked pizza party my
first day out we had some unbelievable
sex like that was about the only
downtime and then right to straight to
work I am happy for you that you're in
such a good place in life and you have
overcome both of you and you seem like
such a powerful influence on him she is
she's my strength it's this situation
right here is is my strength last
question you talked about reading the
Bible regularly for the first time when
you were in prison
are you still doing that do you plan to
make that a part of your yeah you know
what I'm very spiritual and I continue
to you know you know try to practice
that and read the Bible but I've been
home for about four seconds so I guess
only time will tell
[Music]
[Applause]
you